It will be four weeks on Thursday since my pet scans. I noticed a rash on my back a day or two ago after the scans.
I've been taking three drops twice a day of your radiation. I'll be a pet that drops the rash on my back and up into my hairline remains and has spread to my front torso.
Well, I'm not sure that the I'm not sure what the rash is from so certainly I would say that the rash if you do a pet scan or CT scan right the what's the negative of that.
Well, with the pet scan you're getting you have to drink that glucose drink with CT scan and a pet scan you're getting radiation if they did give you anything else as far as a contrast die.
That is simply the radiation that you're exposed to, you're not going to get a rash from the glucose drink, but you certainly could get a rash from a contrast dies. That's that's a chemical change of the radiation.
I'm not heard. I mean, definitely heard of people getting radiation therapy and we'll get a skin burn that looks like a rash, but it's actually a bird of the skin from the ionized radiation.
But I've not heard of a rash from radiation so I don't know that I can certainly be wrong and I don't know that the rash on your back a day or two after the scans was due to the was due to the scans if the scans did not, if you did not get a contrast dying at the scans.
So the radiation homeopath is just to help pull out the radiation out of your body.
Certainly, anything's possible.
But for it to get worse, that just makes me think that it's so what are some possible reasons for a rash. Well, I'll tell you, you know, what are the most so when you think of a rash, you think of a histamine reaction.
On the skin. So what causes a histamine reaction is an allergy to something or at a high exposure to something.
And your so the reason why your body releases histamines is to stimulate
an immune response so if if that thing isn't a pathogen that your immune system can kill, then you're just you and you aren't getting rid of these histamines very well, then that's what causes a rash person that's exposed to, you know, dander of an animal or exposed to pollen they can get a rash or
Or a toxin so a toxic exposure let's say poison ivy you're going to get a rash because of the what's it personal or something that's in poison ivy that oil is an irritant and it's going to cause skin irritation.
So if you have other reasons for rash can be toxins in your body that are being released stress related rash I remember when I was in
school after my first trimester going through my first set of finals after I was after it was done I broke it out into a rash for two weeks, over about two weeks, Christmas vacation was an H.E. horrible rash the entire two weeks and it was completely stress related my adrenals were burned out.
Over the years of practice, just knowing that fact I see that time and time again where people's adrenals are just fried and that is the reason why they break out in a rash.
Has to do with your adrenals ability to interact with the HMT gene which helps you break down history to the tissue so I later.
Figure that out so it's stress and it's that's why stress can cause.
Those things so when you burn out of your cortisol levels and your deals are you know strong adrenal fatigue you can end up with all sorts of problems and rash it just one of them.